if Hollywood studios can make a
franchise out of a property you can bet
it's going to happen some become huge
hits like fast and furious and John wick
but every once in a while things just
don't work out and there's no choice but
to shut down production and move on even
if the story hasn't reached its
conclusion here are a few movie
franchises that ended before their final
chapter Eragon before Twilight and The
Hunger Games
there was arrogance based on a novel of
the same name by Christopher Paolini
released in 2006 the fantasy tale could
have been a for film series but it ended
up serving as a perfect case of a movie
doing fairly well at the box office
while being ripped apart by critics and
audiences and killing the sequels before
they started Paolini has written four
novels in his inheritance cycle series
which means there were three possible
sequels for Eragon and director Stefan
Fangmeier wanted to film them
back-to-back
he told movie web quotes I think one
would be best off to write the third
film first and then being happy with
that going back to the second one and
doing all the set up work that will pay
off in the third then probably filming
two and three together as they did with
Pirates of the Caribbean as one
production end quote unfortunately
things didn't work out in his favor and
arrogance failure halted saying Myers
directing career just as it was getting
off the ground should he ever return to
filmmaking there are a few fans of the
books who would still love to see the
complete Eragon saga unfold on the big
screen Sahara 2005 Sahara looks great on
paper and Indiana jones-style adventures
starring Matthew McConaughey and based
on a best-selling novel by Clive Cussler
it had all the ingredients to become a
summer blockbuster unfortunately Sahara
grossed a mere 119 million dollars
worldwide
despite the studio throwing a hundred
and thirty million dollars into the
project it was that bloated budget that
ultimately brought the action to a
standstill
director breck eisner had hoped to
eventually helm a sequel but once the
HERA hit the books as one of the biggest
financial flops in Hollywood history
according to the Los Angeles Times
any chance of a sequel died with it and
with 18 novels in Cussler's Dirk's hit
series to pull material from paramount
had their hands on a treasure map marked
with a big red X
well you know what they say next never
ever marks this spot JOHN CARTER it took
over 80 years for edgar rice burroughs
classic novel a Princess of Mars to move
from print to screen in the form of 2012
John Carter and the payoff was well less
than spectacular when Disney reacquired
the rights to the story the studio hired
Finding Nemo and wall-e director Andrew
Stanton to helm the film and poured over
300 million dollars into the sci-fi
extravaganza clearly expecting the
classic tale to rake in boatloads at the
box office
spoiler alert it didn't the movie was
such a disaster that the head of Walt
Disney Studios rich Ross actually
resigned his post after John Carter's
release Disney originally had planned
for the film to be the first in a
trilogy when we started on this film we
actually wrote treatments for the first
three films based on the first three for
unfortunately since the film flopped and
interest at Disney waned the rights
reverted to the Burroughs of stayed in
2014 shooting down any hopes of John
Carter - at least with the cast and crew
of the first movie Percy Jackson in the
late 2000s 20th Century Fox hired Chris
Columbus to adapt Rick Riordan Percy
Jackson and the Olympians series for the
big screen Columbus was the perfect
choice for a young adult fantasy flick
after all he directed home alone and the
first two Harry Potter movies and while
Percy Jackson and the Olympians the
lightning thief wasn't as big as Harry
Potter it was still a moderate success
at the box office which was enough to
justify a sequel German filmmakers Thor
Freud and Saul came on to helm the next
installment for as a Jackson to sea of
monsters which saw most of the main cast
returned the movie grossed almost as
much as its predecessor but somewhere
along the line the studio pulled the
plug on the third installment while
Percy Jackson actor Logan Lerman says
that fans are still hoping for a trilogy
he's not optimistic selling daily news
quote I think we are all getting a
little old to play those characters so I
wouldn't hold my breath and quote I am
Number Four
although 2011 I am Number Four grossed
nearly three times its production budget
at the worldwide box office it only made
a hundred
a million dollars apparently not enough
to justify building a whole franchise
it's negative reviews surely didn't help
either the Rotten Tomatoes critics
consensus calls the movie a derivative
and ultimately forgettable sci-fi
thriller shortly after the film's
release in 2011 the film's co-writer
Marti Noxon told Collider that a sequel
was put on the back burner because the
movie wasn't a big enough success at the
box office in 2013
director DJ Caruso said he and the
studios were discussing adapting the
series second novel the power of six but
nothing definitive ever seemed to come
out of those talks divergent as the
Twilight gravy train started coming to
an end
Summit Entertainment looked to Veronica
Roth's divergent book series to fill the
void the young adult dystopian series
came gift-wrapped with a strong fan base
and the first two films divergent and
insurgent did well at the box office
then came the third installment 2016
Allegiant which completely bombed and
forced the studio to hold off on their
plans for a two-part finale stuck with a
dying franchise that demanded a huge
production budget summit decided to
change course and conclude the series by
repurposing the final installment into a
TV series unfortunately the cast and
crew weren't on board with the idea
especially headliner shailene woodley
who told a news that she didn't sign up
for a TV show in February 2017 Woodley
said that she'd officially backed out of
the series making the planned sequel all
the more unlikely
Ender's Game based on the novel of the
same name by Orson Scott Card's 2013's
Ender's Game was given everything it
needed to become a blockbuster which
included nabbing a heavyweight cast
consisting of Harrison Ford Ben Kingsley
asa butterfield
and Hailee Steinfeld but although
Ender's Game garnered generally positive
reviews
it only raked in 125 point 5 million
dollars again staff reduction budget of
110 million not nearly enough to push
the film into sequel worthy territory
despite one cast member suggesting a
script based on Enders shadow a parallel
telling of Ender's Game story budget
constraints prevented the studio from
moving forward with their planned
franchise the studio also considered a
TV spin-off but those plans have also
petered out looks like it's game over
for Ender's Game thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to